[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: With
Cloud Shell Editor,
you can easily run code
from your web browser
and deploy it to the cloud.
In previous videos,
we learned how
to deploy Hello, World
applications to Cloud Run
and Google Kubernetes Engine.
But what if you want to
extend your application
to use other Google Cloud APIs?
Cloud Shell Editor's Cloud
Code integration makes it easy.
Cloud Code is a
set of IDE plugins
that help you stay
productive when developing
cloud-native applications.
In particular, Cloud Code
has a Cloud API section
that helps you easily browse
available Google Cloud APIs,
enable them, and add API client
libraries to your project.
From the Cloud Vision
API to the Cloud Storage
API to the BigQuery API, the
possibilities are endless.
Let's take a look at how to
integrate the Google Cloud
Translate API into a
Python Flask web app.
First, visit
ide.cloud.google.com
to launch Cloud Shell Editor.
Select Terminal, New Terminal to
open a new Cloud Shell terminal
window.
From here, run git clone
to clone the sample code
from GitHub.
Then we'll open the
sample application
as a new workspace with the
cloudshell workspace command.
You can see the list of files
in the Explorer panel located
on the left side of the screen.
In the Cloud Shell
terminal window,
change directories to the
location of the sample app.
To run the sample app locally,
run the following terminal
commands.
Press Command and click on the
URL displayed to open your app.
Congratulations.
If you see this page, that
means you've successfully
run the Hello, World app locally
using Cloud Shell Editor.
Back in the Cloud
Shell terminal window,
press Control-C to
stop the local server.
Now let's set up
credentials so that we
can authenticate
Google Cloud API
requests for local developments.
In the Cloud Shell
terminal window,
run gcloud config set project
to set the Google Cloud
project you want to use,
then run gcloud auth
application-default login.
When prompted in the terminal
if you want to continue,
type in Y and press Enter.
Press Command and click the
link displayed in the terminal.
This opens a new browser tab.
Go ahead and authorize
access to your account.
Copy the authentication
code displayed and paste it
into your terminal.
Now let's go ahead and
integrate a new Cloud API
into our application.
First, click on the API icon on
the left side of your screen.
This opens the API
Explorer, where
you can browse the dozens
of Google Cloud APIs for you
to use.
Select the Cloud
Translation API,
which allows you to
translate between more
than 100 languages.
Under Enable API,
click Enable API.
Under Install Client
Library, select Python.
Lets copy the name of
the translation library
and paste it into our
requirements.txt file,
which lists out Python
libraries we need for our app.
Now we can configure our Python
environment using virtual env
and install
dependencies using pip.
Now that the client
library's installed,
let's translate some text.
Open the web.py file to
edit the Python code.
First, add a line at the top to
import the Translation client
library.
Next, we're going to replace
our existing root directory
code with the following.
This translates the Hello,
World text into Spanish.
Finally, we'll run the updated
application with flask run.
Congratulations.
If you see this page
with the Spanish text,
you successfully integrated
the Cloud Translation API
into your code.
With just a couple
of clicks, we were
able to easily integrate
a new Google Cloud
API into our project.
Want to try this out yourself?
Check out the
interactive tutorial
linked in the description
below, or by launching it
from the Cloud Shell
Editor welcome page.
Thanks for joining us for our
Exploring Cloud Shell Editor
video series.
Make sure to subscribe to the
channel for more great videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]